foreign
ERS welcome to this new video by simply
learn
is your website not ranking as you
thought it would
are there too many competitions out
there
is it getting difficult to capture
relevant audiences
are the solutions suggested too
expensive
do not worry in this video you will get
easy solutions to all your questions as
we have come up with a list of top 10
SEO tools that anyone can use
and the best part is you need not to
spend a single penny on these tools Yes
you heard it right they are free of cost
and are very useful for anyone who wants
to start an online business or
struggling to improve reach so let's
jump right into the list
but before we do kindly subscribe to our
Channel simply learn and hit the Bell
icon to never miss on such interesting
and useful videos
to carry your best SEO practices the
first free tool on our list is the
Keyword Planner
Keyword Planner is a free keyword
research tool provided by Google
drop a keyword research is important as
it increases the possibility to rank
well on the search result Pages the
Keyword Planner will help to discover
new keywords estimate monthly searches a
keyword has
get the cost of ads for the keyword
you're looking for
and help to organize keywords let's
understand how to use Google Keyword
Planner
open your AdWords account
now
go to the tools section and select
Keyword Planner
now you can either add a keyword to get
new insights or upload a CSV file to get
search volumes of already known keywords
let's see how it works
click on discover new keywords
from here you can change the location
enter the key phrase for which you need
keyword insights
click on get results
here you can see all the keyword ideas
related to your keyword phrase
now to get the search volumes of already
known keywords go to the Keyword Planner
and click on get search volume and
forecast
now upload your CSV file from here
here you will get search volumes for all
the keywords
other similar tools with free trials
include
keyword tool dot IO and keyword
generator by RFS
to know trending ideas you can use
Google Trends whereas to get title ideas
you can use the answer the public tool
which is free now let's see the next
tool in the bucket
Google search console Google search
console is a free webmaster tool
provided by Google
it is important to timely monitor your
website and make it error free this is
where Google search console comes into
the picture
it helps businesses to Monitor and
maintain their website's presence in
Google search results some features of
Google Search console includes
getting confirmation that Google search
engine can crawl your website
fix the problems in page indexing sends
Pages for re-indexing
can view Google search traffic data
records the number of times your website
appears in the search results
the search queries for which website
appears in the search result
shows the list of sites linking to you
and many more
let's Now understand how to use Google
search console
here the total Impressions suggests that
number of times your website appears in
the Google search results
whereas the total clicks suggest that
number of times your website is clicked
from the Google search result page
from the covered section
you will get to know all the errors
occurred during the crawling
we recommend you to try your Hands-On
tools like Bing webmaster tool and RFS
which is free for website owners
next up we have the used SEO plugin
used SEO plugin helps in improving your
search results ranking it helps you free
as well as a paid version as a beginner
you can quickly check the free version
it has an inbuilt feature that
automatically carries out SEO analysis
and readability analysis and
automatically adds structured data let's
take a quick look at SEO plugin
from here you can add SEO title
from here you can edit the slug slug is
the part of URL you can add the
necessary keyword here in The Meta
description section you can add the meta
description
which all together looks like this
where this part is your slug the keyword
you want to add in your page should be
added in the Focus key phrase section
the SEO analysis section
shows the SEO improvements in your
content
now moving towards the readability
analysis
readability analysis shows Improvement
in the textual content of the page
if both the indicators are green then
your SEO and readability both are good
to go
for yoast SEO we have covered the
significant features and now we will
understand one of the essential SEO
tools Google Analytics
website tracking plays an important role
in SEO it helps in understanding the
user behavior on your website Google
analytics is an Analytics tool used for
tracking a website
the standard version of Google analytics
is free
we can integrate Google analytics with
Google ads
the main features of Google analytics
include tracking session duration of
users pages per session and tracking
website traffic and bounce rate of users
let's take a quick tour of Google
Analytics
here you can see reports of users for
last seven days
now go to the reports section in the
dashboard
you can reset the time span to get the
desired data from here
go to retention
where you can see the number of new
users and the number of returning users
to your website
to know the data on monetization
go to the monetization section
here you can see the monetization data
for the selected time span
you will understand Google analytics
features and how it works in the
upcoming videos in detail moving ahead
with the next tool which is
small SEO tools puljanism checker
duplicate content is hated by search
engines if not taken seriously this
could hurt your search rankings
the plagiarism Checker detects duplicate
data in your content and shows its
source
you need to open this plagiarism checker
here you can add your content manually
foreign
after adding your content manually you
just need to undergo a verification
and click on check plagiarism
and here we get the results the content
is hundred percent unique
in case if we get any duplicate content
we can check the sources from here
as our content is unique we are not
getting any results here
in case if you don't want to enter your
content manually you can upload document
file from here
note that this Checker checks for the
top thousand words of your content so in
case of lengthy content you can break
the content and then check for its
uniqueness in case you don't want to
purchase the pro version moreover you
can also add a page URL to check the
uniqueness of the content the page has
over here
and follow the same process by clicking
on the check pajarism button
the plagiarism Checker by grammarly is
also one of the free tools used for
checking uniqueness in the content
the next tool that we have in our bucket
is the paid speed insights
spur the data provided by Google the
bounce rate increases to 32 percent as
the page load speed increases from 1 to
3 seconds
page speed insights is the page speed
check tool
page speed insights is used to test the
speed of a web page and it is a free
service offered by Google developers
results of paid speed insights show what
real users are experiencing about your
page on mobile devices and desktops to
understand how to use it let's go to
paid speed insights and select the URL
of the website for which you want to
undergo the check
enter the URL and click on analyze
button
now choose whether you wish to undergo a
check for mobile or desktop device here
I'll select a desktop device
just in few seconds you will get the
required results
another tool that we can use is
tools.pingdom.com which has free as well
as paid versions moving forward to a
next magic tool which is Sim Rush
to grow your business it is essential to
keep an eye on what your competitors are
doing
this will help you to understand their
strengths and Implement similar
strategies for your business as well for
this you need to carry out competitor
analysis
semraj is the competitor analysis tool
that gives complete walkthrough of the
competitors data like keywords
backlinks stop performing content
campaigns
Etc
it has free as well as paid versions
link to semrush is in the description
box below use this link to get a 30-day
free trial for semrush
so let's take a quick overview of how it
works
login to your sem Rush account
here enter the URL of your competitor
here you can choose a geographical
location for which the analysis is to be
performed
by adding URL you get all the competitor
data here I have added sem Rush as a
competitor so we are getting so many
details of sem Rush The Organic keywords
the organic traffic paid keywords paid
traffic referral domains and Authority
score
we can add a competitor as well from
here
now here you can see the data of both
sem rush and RFS
other than sem rush you can use spyfu
which has some free daily trials now let
me tell you about an excellent auditing
tool
which is screaming frog
dear Learners it is essential to know
how your website is performing and for
this you need to carry out frequent
website audits
screaming frog is a website auditing
tool that works similar to web crawlers
it has free as well as paid versions
some features of free version include
finding broken links errors and
redirects analyzing page title and
metadata
href Lang attributes auditing finding
duplicate content
Etc with a crawl limit of 500 urls
let's know more about it go to screaming
frog
now
from here download the tool on your
system
check various resources provided
on how to learn the tool from here
another alternative tool you can use for
auditing is seability where you can
enter the URL and get the audit reports
moving further with another free tool
which is rf's backlink checker
gaining high quality backlinks is an
essential factor for SEO ranking as it
shows the trust of other websites in
your content moreover it helps in
building the authority of your website
with the help of backlink Checker you
get the data of all the websites linking
to your website rf's backlink Checker
shows the data of top 100 backlinks top
5 anchors and top 5 Pages including
total number of backlinks and referring
domains in its free version
let's have a quick look at the tool
here let's take example of wikipedia.com
so here we are checking backlinks for
wikipedia.com
now click on check backlink
here we got details of backlinks for
wikipedia.com
alternatives to rf's backlink Checker
are SCM Rush backlink Analytics tool and
seability
by signing up with these tools you will
get some free trials for your site last
but not the least let's know about the
mobile SEO tool which is mobile friendly
test
studies show that in year 2020 60 of
traffic was through mobile devices thus
it is essential to keep your website
mobile friendly as well
here is when the mobile friendly test
comes into action
it helps to check if your website is
mobile friendly or not go to mobile
friendly test
and enter the URL of your website
suppose I enter your www.wikipedia
.com
now click on test URL
here you get the results
we can see that the pages mobile
friendly
to check more details you can navigate
to your search console account
well if you think we are done for today
then then keep watching this video as we
have two bonus tools for you
so here comes the first one
the separator
search results vary with mobile devices
also your brand ranking May differ from
country to Country
to get reports on this separator will be
your all-time companion if it shows how
search results May differ for mobile
devices or locations
let's see how it works
go to separator
now
let's fill in the required fields
now
let's select the location
let's run the live test
and here we get the results
that's it daily you can run three free
live tests isn't this amazing
without taking a minute let's know about
the second bonus tool
which is
the rich results test
you must have seen these kinds of search
results on search pages
let's dive deep into it
yes these type of results are known as
Rich results
to check whether your site is optimized
for Rich results
go to Rich results test
and add the URL of your website let's
add the URL of Simply learn
now click on test URL
complete the verification
and check the report
so here we can see that simply learns
website is eligible for Google searches
Rich results
to monitor Rich results for your
complete website you can easily navigate
to your search console account
here we end the session I hope you got
the best knowledge about free SEO tools
stay tuned with simply learn for more
such interesting videos don't forget to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon for more updates
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here